[Music]
i said initially going to talk about why
i think it works to have a relatively
small state
and
most human activity an overwhelming
majority of it being in the private
sector and relatively low taxes light
touch regulation
and the rest of it and i'm going to
refer you to one
book or piece of research which i think
goes a long way to making uh that point
and my case and this is a piece of
research that is produced by uh the
fraser institute
which is a canadian think tank fras er
if you google it you'll find them and if
you google fraser institute economic
freedom of the world index you'll find
out
you'll easily find the index that i'm
referring to
now what the fraser institute do in
their freedom index is they try to
rank the freedom that exists in 162
economies across the world using
43 different indices of measurement
so what they're really trying to do is
just to discover as objectively as you
can because there's you know you're
sometimes comparing apples with pears or
oranges with bananas but trying to work
out of the 162 economies in the world uh
which are
the most classical liberal and which are
the least classically liberal
so they'll measure things like
the size of government
uh in their view the smaller the better
the bigger the worse the legal system
does the rule of law exist or do you
tend to have to bribe officials or deal
with organized crime uh property rights
is it obvious who owns what or their
endless property disputes because there
isn't a proper system of land registry
for example
does the economy work on sound money or
is the government continually reprinting
its bank notes with two noughts on the
end of them or can you trust the
government's money supply
what's the freedom to trade
internationally can you buy products in
from other countries if you want to and
sell to other countries if you want to
uh and what's the regulatory framework
is the government incredibly
prescriptive about exactly how you need
to run your business exactly what you've
got to employ uh pay your employees
exactly uh what health and safety
measures you need to take on the stairs
or the production line or is it
relatively light touch those are some
indications
of the metrics they use and the idea
behind this report is to find out really
whether adopting across those 43 indices
pro freedom approaches and policies
is the it brings with it successful
outcomes so what we can do is to compare
basically
the most classical liberal the most
capitalist you might say economies and
to compare that information to see if
those economies have better outcomes for
their citizens compared to what you
might call more socialist more
interventionist economies with a much
bigger state
and less role for the individual um
so
to try and enable that that analysis to
take place
uh to see if there is a correlation
between economic freedom classical
liberalism and human well-being uh the
this index uh the economic freedom of
the world index uh splits the 162
economies into quartiles into four
groups
based on their level of economic freedom
a bit like i guess our four football
divisions in england this is a premier
league uh going all the way down to the
league two or the fourth division as it
used to be said and they'll put
the fraser institute will put the most
classical liberal societies in the
premier league
and the least liberal and free societies
in league two and then we can compare
these different groups are the more
socialist economies doing well or the
um
or the uh more liberal classical liberal
free market economies doing well
and the results in my view are so
staggering that even if you have
complaints about the exact methodology
the evidence is overwhelming and the
jury is in
if you want the people in your society
to be
healthy wealthy wise
happy insofar as that can be measured
then classical liberalism free market
capitalism is unambiguously uh the way
forward and the tools that you should
adopt so let me give you some of those
statistics without just i don't want to
machine gun you with endless numbers but
let me talk through some of them so i've
made a lot of assertions here but i
haven't made any i haven't given you any
proof let's look at uh
average incomes
uh income's not the only thing that
matters to people but i guess it matters
quite a lot something that we discuss a
lot we get worried if incomes in britain
are going down which clearly they are at
the moment in the lockdown uh but let's
look at the average income in that uh
top quartile of countries and by top i
mean the most classically liberal
and compare it to the 25 percent of
countries that are the least free they
have the highest taxes the biggest state
the highest regulation the worst rule of
law and the rest of it and what you find
is in the
uh freer countries the most classically
liberal ones average incomes are six
times higher so in those top 25
countries from a classical liberal
perspective the average income is
a little bit higher than 36 000 u.s
dollars
and in the worst 25 that bottom division
the average income is just a little
above 6 000 us dollars so there's a
remarkable
stunning correlation at least between
being classical liberal broadly
capitalist in free market and having
high average
incomes
uh but what's interesting as well
because i can anticipate a question will
be oh yeah well it might be the rich
benefit but what about the poor uh if
you're averaging it out that might just
be because there's lots of billionaires
and millionaires but the people at the
bottom of a capitalist free market
classical liberal society suffering far
more than they would in a socialist
society no the gap here is even more
staggering so if you look at the bottom
10
of income earners in different countries
the lowest 10
and you look at the lowest 10 percent
in
capitalist countries classical liberal
countries and the lowest 10
in the least classically liberal
countries then actually you the the
difference is seven times higher income
in the richer countries so if you're
going to be in the bottom 10
of the country that you live in
uh you still definitely definitely want
to be living in a relatively free market
liberal capitalist country not in a
socialist one even more so than the
average earner if you're an average
earner you appear to be six times better
off earning six times as much money
as in the more socialist societies but
if you're on that bottom ten percent
you're seven times better off than you
would be if you were in the bottom 10 of
a poorer society um
similarly if you were looking at not
just the bottom 10 but extreme absolute
adjective poverty i think this is
defined by the world bank of trying to
get by on a salary of or income of less
than uh
1.90 a day
uh that's reckoned to be about the point
that you're probably below subsistence
uh you know nearly all you know one hell
of a challenge to
stay alive so how many people are uh
struggling on those appalling uh income
levels well again if you look at the
fourth division the least classically
liberal countries about 27
of people in those countries are living
in that extreme poverty in utter
destitution more than a quarter
struggling to even live
and if you look at the most classically
liberal economies those with relatively
lower taxes less regulation and less of
a role for a state there is still abject
poverty but it's a bit less than two
percent of the population who live in
the freer countries so what we see
pretty clearly if you like almost
whichever group you wish to compare with
whichever group whether you want to
compare the average citizen in
relatively in free market countries to
the average citizen in socialist
countries whether you want to compare
the bottom 10 of the citizenry with the
bottom 10 percent of the citizenry or
whether you actually want to look at how
many you know how good is each society
at making sure that people aren't living
in absolute devastating poverty then
there is no doubt you want to be in that
classical liberal free-market catalyst
league of clubs
you want to be low tax low regulation
low government spending
uh good quality rule of law and the rest
uh but it's not just about economics uh
you'll probably be unsurprised to know
that the other metrics that we might
care about are um
produce better results in classical
liberal countries than in their
socialist counterparts uh so
if you want to live longer uh well you
want to be in that top quartile of the
most free market countries in the world
you will on average uh live 14 years
longer than someone who is in the least
classical liberal quartile that fourth
division of countries
uh
other metrics you might want to look at
i'll say infant mortality that top
quartile of countries the most classical
liberal
their infant mortality rate is six times
lower than the bottom 25 percent the
most socialist countries
and you can look at a whole range of
other
measures as well if you like
non-economic factors that you might
consider have real value and you'll find
that the
most classical liberal countries have
far greater political and civil
liberties greater gender equality
and the extent to which you think you
can measure things and this is a hazy
area seem to indicate that they're
happier countries
as well
so it seems to me that the case is uh
pretty overwhelmingly
strong that uh if you want those things
longer life less
less people dying in child death higher
incomes not just for the affluent but
for the average the poor and a lack of
destitution the the the evidence is in
according to the fraser institute you
want to be one of the classical liberal
countries
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas